good evening I'm Beverly wheeler
president of the Alumni Association I'm
pleased be he introduced a distinguished
alumnus who present this evenings talk
entitled moneth from Carnegie Mellon
University to academic medicine dr.
Hillard Lazarus dr. Lazarus is a tenured
professor professor of medicine at Case
Western Reserve University and he
practices at university hospitals case
Medical Center in the division of
hematology oncology where he was
director of the blood and marrow
transplant program for more than 25
years and currently serves as director
of novel self novel cell therapies
university hospitals case Medical Center
case comprehensive cancer center he led
a sustained an innovative clinical and
translational research program focused
on chemotherapy dose escalation and
blood and marrow transplantation for
improving therapy of malignant disorders
his seminal impact in multiple aspects
of transplantation was recognized in
1986 wise invitation to develop and
chair the blood and marrow transplant
committee of the national cancer
institute funded eastern cooperative
oncology group a position he held until
2003 for the past decade he has been the
principal investigator of the case
consortium of the blood and marrow
transplant clinical trials Network an
organization funded by the National
Cancer Institute and the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute these groups
provide national leadership in the
development of a new clinical trials for
blood and marrow transplantation for the
treatment of leukemia
lymphoma melanoma and aplastic anemia
dr. Lazarus is internationally
recognized for his contributions in the
areas of mesenchymal stem cell
transplantation autologous blood and
marrow transplantation for lymphoma and
all allogeneic blood and marrow
transplantation for malignancies these
efforts included the development of many
new anti-cancer therapies and
sophisticated supportive care
technologies he has been identified as
an outstanding physician in many
regional and national surveys and was
inducted into the Cancer Care Hall of
Fame American Cancer Society he has over
400 publications and is an editor of six
textbooks in the field of blood and bone
marrow transplantation hematologic
malignancies and supportive care for
cancer patients he has been a gifted
teacher and mentor to countless medical
residents fellows and junior faculty
influencing many to pursue careers in
academic medicine including blood stem
cell transplantation please join me in
welcoming 2011 alumni distinguished
achievement award honoree dr. Hillard
Lazarus thank you very much for that
terrific introduction I hope I can keep
you engaged in a wake while I tell you
about my experiences and I would like to
begin by saying that I'm very humbled
that I was chosen for this award and my
most sincere thanks for all the folks at
you at Carnegie Mellon for giving me
such a wonderful education and helping
with my my life's experiences I wanted
to say some things about myself and my
experiences at Carnegie Mellon before I
tell you about
what I have done with my career as a
result of my training here and I would
start with my first slide basically
telling you what my passions are
certainly my family and my wife is here
sitting in the front row along with my
my parents in my aunt and uncle I'm also
passionate about and a sore loser about
dealing with cancers I was hoping and i
will show you some data where we've
really pushed back the frontiers of
these dreaded diseases but my passions
also include carnegie mellon university
as you're here and of course the
Pittsburgh Steelers I'm a Pittsburgh
person and never miss a game this is my
my my wife is sitting in the front row
my love of my life and my best friend
and this is one of our family
get-togethers at a recent family wedding
and you can see that's very important to
me I've been very blessed by having
great medical mentors these three
gentlemen are internationally recognized
this gentleman birch Griggs was a
professor at the University of Rochester
were obtained my undergrad my medical
degree and then the man who invented the
science of blood coagulation Oscar Ratan
off at Case Western and finally a nathan
berger who is currently a former dean in
cancer center directory at directorate
case who have provided me with great
insight valuable advice and great
inspiration now if you look at this book
this is a book on the bestseller of the
New York Times outliers the story is
success by Malcolm Gladwell and in this
text he describes a lot of things that
lead to success in life and one of them
is luck but I don't think it's luck that
I ended up at Carnegie Mellon I was born
and raised in Pittsburgh and I would
maybe it's more faith than I ended up at
Carnegie Mellon but I can say that in my
life this time I spent here was among
the greatest period of my life some of
the best years here on this campus this
is the mug for my fraternity
I have a fraternity brother in the
audience our fraternities morphed a
little bit it's still on the campus this
is where I developed a lot of
camaraderie and leadership I got to do a
lot of things in the internal in the
intramural athletics program and as a
student on this campus all the great
things that we have to do the homecoming
floats and the homecoming is this week
the booths at Spring Carnival the the
greek sing the parties the mixers this
is a great great educational experience
but it's also a great social experience
for students and this is a very near and
dear to my heart I would argue that for
Carnegie Mellon I think the logo should
have we can do as part of the the mantra
because I think that's part of the
culture here and I'll show you that as I
go through my presentation I was very
fortunate early in my campus experience
to have to Carnegie Mellon mentors who
put me on the path to my success much
like the the man I showed you from the
University of Rochester and then case
western reserve university and
photographs of these gentlemen from the
pastor shown here george boole ELO and
ken Ken hung and these gentlemen began a
fledgling biotechnology department in
the it was a sub unit of bots of the
civil engineering and they were working
on very interesting projects in blood
blood red blood cells and circulation
and other things and I got very
interested and I decided I wanted to
apply engineering to medicine and that's
in fact how I've spent my entire career
they were instrumental in helping me as
an undergraduate student connect up with
the surgeon over at west penn hospital
and the more i was exposed to medicine
the more I realized how great medicine
was and why I wanted to put my training
into medicine these two gentlemen also
were very helpful getting me into
medical school because I if I was not
the first carnegie-mellon student who
made it to medical school I certainly
was one of the first this was something
that was someone unheard of and in fact
is one of the reasons why i say we can
do because whenever I ask for help they
were but would bend over backwards and
make sure that all the necessary things
happen I had an occasion to see King
Kong Hong da recently he's at the ease
and bile engineering at the University
of Pittsburgh and he's still a very
active researcher and he has again
continued to be a guiding light for me
the things that I learned at Carnegie
Mellon I think are shown in this slide
these are traits that most of us have in
some form but they were enhanced here
the work-study ethic how to think
critically and solve problems that's
what engineers and appliance scientists
do we have to work together and now the
buzzword as you know is is networking I
don't think that word really existed but
that's what we did and we also route
reveled in the discovery and learning
things and it was a very passionate
exciting time to be a student here and
all of these things had helped shape me
has who i am and i have carried this
weekend in philosophy throughout my
career and when I come back to visit at
Carnegie Mellon it's more pronounced
than ever I didn't want to tell you
about getting into Medical School and
what I have done with my medical career
as you heard from the introduction I
wanted to deal with patients that had
malignancies and at the time I started
malignancies there weren't very many
drugs there weren't very many effective
surgical approaches and most patients
did not do well that's clearly not the
case anymore and it's like seeing a man
on getting a man on the moon or the
Berlin Wall coming down in your lifetime
to see so many phenomenal successes in
such a short time is greatly rewarding
I've been able to be productive enough
to
have a rank of Professor and a major
medical center and I've been able to not
only lead and give guidance to a marrow
transplant program but I've been able to
to work with young people and help them
get into a career in medicine which i
think is really one of our goals and i
think is often overlooked in this area
of being counting so what I'm going to
show you and then the remaining part of
my talk is what I have done and I hope
this is presented in a way that you can
understand it because it's a lot of this
is shop Talk and I don't want it to be
that way my area of expertise is in
dealing with blood disorders and this is
what's called a blood smears is when you
take a drop of blood and you smear it on
a slide and you stain it and you see
different cells that have names these
purple things are white blood cells that
fight infection the red things are red
blood cells that carry oxygen and these
little things are called platelets and
they're critical to making blood clot
when we when we have an injury they're
made in the factory the factory is
called the bone marrow and the bone
marrow is the inside of a bone if you go
to a skeleton and hold up a bone it's
hollow but if you go to a butcher shop
and you look at a bone that's been cut
in half it's filled with red material
that we call bone marrow and this is a
these photomicrographs these are
pictures of the Microsoft the bone
marrow looks like these are very very
small cells and there's they're very
rich with cells as you can see but
there's also these big open spaces that
are are filled with fat and so that's
what a normal bone marrow looks like
it's relatively cellular when people get
chemotherapy to get rid of cancer there
are different kinds of cancers some of
the cancers are more sensitive to
chemotherapy shown on this curve as a
the orange curve that's that some more
chemotherapy kills more cancer yo fewer
cells but many cancers are relatively
insensitive and even if you give a
higher doses
treatment you don't get rid of the
cancer the other problem is that when
you give chemotherapy the bone marrow
the factory is damaged as well as the
cancer and this leads to low blood
counts low blood counts leads to
infection leads to bleeding and leads to
serious injury and this is what the bone
marrow looks like in a person who has
been given chemotherapy so here again
for comparison on the lower panel is
this very rich lots of cells in the and
the relatively normal or untreated
marrow but these top panels show that
the bone marrow has been damaged
significantly by chemotherapy and the
ability to make blood is reduced and you
can see in that situation they need for
transplantation that is if you could
give more treatment to a patient working
in the therapy and somehow get around to
damage to the bone marrow then you would
have a useful modality and in fact
that's what bone marrow transplant is
it's basically a rescue the idea is that
the the bone marrow that you're giving
back restores blood production and you
can make the blood cells get back to
normal fight off infection fight off
bleeding and help the patient during
this very difficult time there are many
kinds of bone marrow transplants you've
certainly read about it Hollywood makes
a lot of movies bone marrow can be
collected from the bone marrow itself or
as I'll show you on a subsequent a
couple slides the field has evolved that
we are able to fool the bone marrow by
giving patients County a different
agents and the bone marrow cells that
normally stay in the bone marrow will
leave the bone marrow go out into the
blood and it's a lot easier to collect
blood from an individual than to have to
put a needle into their hip and I'll
show you what this looks like from a
technical standpoint now the two major
distinctions are donating your boner for
yourself there are situations where you
can give your own bone marrow other
situations where you can get it from a
brother or sister who is the same bone
marrow type
or even someone that can in the
community at large this is referred to
the lady that introduced me the term is
she used term a low generic that means
from another person and there are people
in the world somewhere in the world who
may have the same bone marrow type as
you the problem is the likelihood of
finding a donor is I'll show you on a
cartoon is much more common in your
immediate family than in the world at
large but nonetheless it's possible now
the bone marrow cells all start from
oneself there is a great grandfather
cell that we call a stem cell that lives
in the bone marrow and this cell will
grow and divide and ultimately give rise
to all blood production so from this new
yorker cartoon I'm joking that one scoop
of ice cream can lead to many many
different products in that term is
differentiation it's a little bit more
complicated when you show in actuality
as the red arrow shows up here the
grandfather's sell this stem cell that
gives rise to all blood production that
lives in the bone marrow is a very
complicated cell but this is the cells
this is the cell we want and if we
transfer this cell you can restore blood
production to the person who's in need
of this of the bone marrow transplant
and the the different kinds of
transplants are again showed here on
this slide we match bone marrow very
differently when we match red blood
cells so those of you who have gone to
blood banks and know your blood type is
o or it's a B or it's all a red red
blood cells haven't typing and bone
marrow typing are very very different
people can be matched through a much
more complicated system that is called
HLA but also as I've described to you
people who are not related to you
somewhere in the world may have the same
bone marrow type as you and this is is
the forms the background for how we
proceed with transplantation now in my
career we started out trying to figure
out what drugs we could use that we
could expand and given much higher doses
to kill off more kamath more cancer
again when I showed you is more
chemotherapy kills more cancer and if
you could support the person you could
cure more cancers the problem is we
don't want to lose patients do two
marrow failure from infection bleeding
or other things one of the first drugs
that we started with is shown here this
is a drug called cytarabine this is a
drug dis given by vein and it's very
commonly used in the treatment of
leukemia we in the late in the mid in
the late 1970s at Case Western Reserve
University systematically started a
series of studies in many many patients
with end of the line leukemia where we
were able to demonstrate that we could
give higher and higher doses of this
particular drug to these patients where
we ended up interestingly not only
getting rid of the Leukemia in some of
these people but actually curing these
patients of this very dreaded disease by
giving as I showed on this line 30 times
the dose that was given before and this
is a was a clue that this approach of
intensive treatment was going to be
something that people should start and
in fact right now this approach with
high-dose cytarabine is standard
treatment so I've had an opportunity to
participate in developing something that
standard around the world now similarly
people started looking in the early
1980s at transplantation not only for
bone marrow but for other organs as you
can see here on this cover of Newsweek
from 1983 as as the medical science I've
got further and further understanding
more and more about how the body can
tolerate an organ from one person versus
an organ from another well we did the
science of immunology more and more
transplants were done and in fact the
University of Pittsburgh not very far
from here became the world's leader in
liver transplants and solid organ
transplants of that nature that was in
the early 1980s and this slide shows you
that transplantation has exploded so if
we look back here on the on the
horizontal axis in the
in 70's transplants were not done very
commonly and over a period of time many
many more transplants were being done in
part from results that we and others
have published showing that you could
use your own bone marrow that's in the
gray area the that's the word autologous
and other marrow from other people and
different types of cells to the point
that we're now starting to cure people
who really were going to die of their
disease in very short time and this is
these are data i'll show you these are
called survival curves they'll show a
few of these this graphs the the
likelihood or the percent of patients
surviving on the vertical axis as a
function of the time x 0 being when you
did the transplant onward in months or
years or in this case in decades we were
the first group who took people that had
essentially end of the line lymphoma
hodgkin lymphoma and other kinds of
lymphoma and used bone marrow transplant
after high doses of chemotherapy we were
only able to cure twenty percent of
these end of the line patients but
that's twenty percent of people who
would have died from their disease and
right now this is one of the standards
of how to approach people who have
lymphoma that has come back after a
conventional chemotherapy now the field
has been moving forward and you can see
on this curve that and history tends to
repeat itself as we are all familiar
with the the nuclear disaster in japan
just recently this was the story of
chernobyl where over in Russia there was
a big nuclear accident and then a large
number of people were exposed to
radiation and actually got a very close
friend of mine Robert Peter Hill was the
American physician who went over to
Russia to do transplantation and this
captivated the world and people started
noticing the transplantation was
potentially a curative a curative option
you can see this is from Life magazine
in 1986 such that now this is standard
fare in many places around the world the
transplantation not only is it
curative for getting rid of cancer but
it can also get rid of Mara that's been
damaged from radiation accidents from
immunologic diseases or from inborn
errors there are people that are born
with immune systems that don't work so
that's how we have gotten to where we
are I mentioned earlier that the way we
collect we used to collect bone marrow
was a very arduous process where an
individual you can see this person is
lying on his or her side and novocaine
and is put into the hip bone in the back
and then you can see that the needle is
directed through that bone into the area
where it's sucked out with the syringe
and it's relatively uncomfortable to
have this done so this is done with
people put to sleep we don't do this
anymore in the mid and late 1980s we and
other centers figured out a way to fool
the bone marrow to throw bone marrow
cells out into the blood and to collect
them in the blood and that's shown on
this cartoon so what you can see on this
the term is mobilization so the red line
here is a blood vessel that has all
these cells in it and with the bone
marrow being tickled or provoked in a
certain fashion the white bone marrow
cells leave the bone marrow go in you
can see the arrow they leave the bone
marrow they go into the blood vessel and
we collect them using automated
instruments and don't have to put people
to sleep and as a result of that we can
actually collect much more bone marrow
cells so this is sort of the the
distillate of the major technological
where have we gone why we gotten so much
better transplantation is now done
throughout the world with high degrees
of success we have been able to develop
newer chemotherapeutic agents as I'll
show you we are able to make it safer
and easier for patients to get through
chemotherapy we have had experiences in
developing new anti-nausea medications
that people are not nearly as sick as
they used
to be and of course we have not only
better antibiotics and better ways of
giving blood transfusions but also we
have many many more donors as I'll show
you an another slide now one of the ways
that one of the tricks of getting the
bone marrow cells to leave the bone
marrow to go onto the blood is to give
them as to give the recipient or the
patient growth factors now this is not
going to make you grow taller or great
or have you grow great muscles like
Arnold Schwarzenegger these are
substances that exist in all of us but
in very very very tiny quality
quantities such that with marvels of
genetic engineering were able to take
the gene that makes these substances put
them into a bacteria and grow up large
numbers of this myth this material in
tissue culture purify it and then make
it available as shown here on this slide
to be able to give these products to the
patients and have this happen we're also
able to administer a lot of these
treatments much more easily and readily
and with less discomfort for the patient
by doing what's using what's called a
central venous catheter what this means
is that instead of and you may all have
had this experience of having somebody
stick a needle in your hand or in your
arm or starting an IV in a regular basis
a surgeon can very succinctly put in a
catheter this plastic tube right under
the front of the chest they can stay
under the skin that's what the dotted
line means under the skin and then this
catheter can be used to give all the
blood transfusions and the antibiotics
and all the things that's necessary now
i'm going to show you the two major
classes of transplant and some of the
data so autologous means self transplant
you are donating blood cells for
yourself this is a very complicated area
just understand that there are people in
whom we can collect the normal blood
cells and not collect bad cells we can
freeze those cells and give them back
this is an
pages because you don't have to go look
for a donor the cells are not going to
be rejected because they're yours but
there is there are some side effects or
downside to this partly because many of
the people that were collecting bone
marrow cells have already been exposed
to chemotherapy and the cells may have
been damaged and this is the cartoon of
how this works you identify a patient
who is a candidate for a transplant for
him self or herself we collect the cells
out of the blood as I've described to
you then freeze the cells then give the
patient's very high doses of
chemotherapy then go to the freezer take
the cells out of the freezer for them
give them back and as a transfusion the
cells know to go through the bloodstream
and home back into the bone marrow and
start to grow they do not grow
instantaneously they usually take about
two or three weeks to grow back this is
why people have to be hospitalized and
have to get antibiotics to prevent or
treat infection and have to give get
blood transfusions because they're not
making blood but when that is all worn
off then hopefully the disease has come
under good control now again in the
course of my career we were able to
develop one of these drugs to the point
that this drug is now used worldwide for
the treatment of certain malignancies we
took a drug that had been underutilized
and used in very low dose melville and
that's shown here in this product and
this is a drug that works by killing the
DNA of tumor cells that's what this
panel here shows it's a very active drug
we were able to demonstrate through a
series of many many studies and patients
that we could give almost ten times the
dose of this drug when we gave the
patients their own bone marrow back and
this resulted in a much much higher
likelihood of getting rid of the
malignancy this was such a sentinel
event that the initial report that I
wrote which is shown up here in 1983
I was recognized by one of the
prestigious medical societies that 25
years later they asked my permission to
republish the original article from 1983
in its form and asked and asked me and
my colleagues to provide an editorial of
what what has happened in the ensuing 25
years and we did this this is now
standard fare for people to have certain
kinds of malignancy especially multiple
myeloma which is a very devastating
illness pardon me the other area that we
have spent a lot of time improving is in
the area of a low genetic transplant so
very different than using cells from
yourself allergenic means you have to
have somebody who's a donor or first of
all willing to be a donor and next of
all has the same bone marrow type as you
if we took somebody who did not have the
same bone marrow type and gave them gave
your boat their bone marrow to you it
wouldn't grow would be rejected so you
need some kind of matching and has to be
the same these are cells from a normal
donor that's an advantage and these
cells from the normal person have the
ability to recognize and kill cancer
cells which is something that is lacking
in a person who gets cells from
themselves the autologous or they
wouldn't it had cancer develop in the
first place so there's advantages of
using another person but the
disadvantages not only made these cells
from the normal person attack the cancer
but they might recognize that person's
liver or intestines or skin is being
different and caused an attack that is
known as graft versus host disease
that's shown here on this slide graft
meaning the cells from the other person
host is the recipient and this is a
problem so how do we know somebody's a
match well this court this cartoon and
the cartoon and the next slide show that
the bone marrow type much like red blood
cell type or other things the ABO
example that I gave you is inherent
so on this cartoon the round circles are
females and the square circles are men
so here we have a man and a woman that
have three children and these long
addresses I've made color-coded so you
can see the difference this is how we
talk about the bone marrow type it's a
very complicated system that you can see
from this cartoon that mom and dad come
together and each parent gives one gene
to each of their children so each
everybody has two genes and in this case
the mom gives the red gene to her
daughter and the red gene to the son
while dad gives the green gene to the
same a daughter and son and there is a
match you can see that light up and this
brother over here Oh is not affected
doesn't match but that doesn't matter so
we have a good situation we can do a
transplant between the brother and the
patient on the other hand here's a
situation where they don't match up
where you can see that mom and dad's
genetic situation was such that the two
brothers match each other but the
patient is left out in the cold what
does that mean well I've already told
you that there's many many people in the
world who may have the same bone marrow
type as you the problem is it's like
needle in a haystack over the last
several decades places agencies like the
Department of Defense the Navy over in
Europe there's a whole bunch of a whole
number of agencies they have screened
normal donors so that there's 15 million
altruistic people in the world who we
have their DNA typing on and we know
what their bone marrow type is you can
dial up literally on a computer to find
somebody so if it's one in a million
chance of finding somebody out there and
there's 15 million you may not have a
brother or sister who's a donor but you
might have an unrelated donor and this
is how we're able to do this sort of
thing the chronology of doing a
transplant between a brother and a
sister or someone who is unrelated in a
patient is shown here it's a little bit
different than what i showed you for the
and the autologous situation because now
we have two individuals involved with
the red is the patient and you can see
in this case the patient is evaluated
the patient's going to give very high
doses of chemotherapy to get rid of the
cancer and the patient is going to get a
graft but it's not the person's own
graph that's been collected before it's
from the donor who has to be agreeable
and we certainly don't want to put the
donor at risk and for me this is why
there are so many safeguards in place
and and this is done worldwide with very
very few bad things happening to a
normal person who's of course we have to
protect them at all costs and then we do
the transplant by giving the cells back
giving that person antibiotics and
transfusions until the bone marrow can
grow back and one other wrinkle here we
have to ferment remember that the cells
from the other person can attack the
person in question graft-versus-host
disease we have to take steps to prevent
that from happening and you can see much
like I showed you in an earlier slide
the worldwide donation history has
exploded there are millions and millions
of people who donate blood or bone
marrow for their fellow mankind and in
fact there's even umbilical cord blood
which I'll comment on a second now just
to run through some of these data this
is a very brief series of survival
curves this is one of the studies that
we showed that we are able to cure about
half of the people with lymphoma that's
relapsed after treatment remember the
first study I showed you we were only
about successful and twenty percent now
we're successful in more than half of
the people that have this disease I wish
I could tell you that we could do this
and everybody it's a little harder to do
it and older people and not all the
elderly are the same for those of you in
the audience that's Keith Richards from
the Rolling Stones if you don't know
that and the other ones I hope you can
recognize but we have been able to to
with
better supportive care better
antibiotics better transfusions the
growth factors and other things do this
in even much older folks where this was
never done before leading to much
success and I'll skip that slide other
than to show you that in the past few
decades we've gotten better and better
and better at doing this these are just
a series of curves showing that the
likelihood of surviving and these
diseases is getting better and better
except the big hurdle still is this
graft versus host disease this is a
cartoon showing it's the agony in the
ecstasy graft-versus-host disease is
good the graft attacking the cancer
normal cells getting rid of the cancer
it's bad because the graph sometimes may
attack the recipient and the cells may
not grow so that's still the Holy grill
much like in the Middle East there can
be tolerance and date on tour whatever
topic you whatever language you want to
use it takes a long time if a person
gets a transplant from another person
and you can keep them going and out of
the hospital usually over a period of a
number of years the war between the sum
of the donors bone marrow and the person
goes away that's what's shown on this
slide the term tolerance you can see how
the this graft versus host these
eventually distinct extinguishes and
these slides just remind us that people
who get some graft-versus-host disease
are going to do better because the
disease the malignancy is killed off by
the graph now to make it even more
complicated but better for patients
we're not we figured out we don't miss
some people have to give as much
treatment and I'm going to quote
Shakespeare were a little more than a
little is by much too much this
basically means that there are some
situations where if it's a situation of
doing a transplant between two different
people we may not have to give all of
the chemotherapy at the same time to get
rid of the malignancy so to put it in in
football terms if it's second down in 20
edge to go you don't have to get it all
in one place maybe you can get it on 10
yards and 10 yards and get a first down
and that's what's shown here on this
cartoon the idea here in in is now we
use what's called reduced-intensity
conditioning transplant in other words
the transplant is not as intense as it
has been because the idea is that you
give enough chemotherapy to allow the
patient's immune system not to reject
the graph and not and still killing off
cells so that you get a partial in
grafton or some of the cells are growing
so the donor is in red I'm sorry is in
yellow the donor is in red and you can
see that after in the first few weeks of
the first few months the person has a
mixture of their own bone marrow and the
end the marrow that they that they got
from the donor but over a period of time
their own bad cells go away and
eventually the graft is from the other
person has got rid of the cells when
that is done it is much safer for the
recipient and today were able to through
better understanding of immunology we're
able to provide a graph for almost
everybody I'm sure you remember hearing
or seeing in the newspaper on TV
somebody's brother or sister didn't
match and that was almost the end of the
world not true volunteer donors and
other things I'll show you a brief bit
about up umbilical cord blood graphs the
unrelated donors because of the way we
understand matching are providing almost
as good a result as a brother or sister
that's what this curve shows these
curves the brother or sister graft and
the unrelated donor craft are almost
superimposable and we have even the
issue of collecting grafts from the
placenta the afterbirth this is when a
baby is delivered the umbilical cord is
tied off and the afterbirth is delivered
remember the placenta the afterbirth is
the machine in the mother's womb that
keeps the baby alive it's it provides
all the nutrients
and all the blood and all these other
things that was formerly discarded now
these cells can be collected by the
obstetrician after the baby has been
delivered they can be frozen and they
can they too can be used and this is a
curve basically showing that you can do
this kind of transplant and have very
very successful outcomes there are still
some worked a lot of work to be done
i've mentioned graft-versus-host disease
also people who undergo a transplant
tend to have problems with acceleration
of the aging process that means they get
cataracts at a younger age they have
dental caries they get osteoporosis and
younger age they have a lot of things
that happen to them but we're working on
that area and the fuel remaining minutes
of my talk I wanted to share with you
another stem cell area that I've been
fortunate to spend in my career that has
been a very very rewarding and as part
of my some of my new duties this is an
area where we recognize on a campus at
Case Western Reserve University that
there's not only a grandfather cell in
the bone marrow of the stem cell that
makes blood but there's a grandfather
cell on the bone marrow it's referred to
as a mesenchymal stem cell this is a
cell that makes the supporting area for
the bone marrow in other words the cell
that that makes the house in which the
people live the bone marrow is the
people living in the house the house is
the the bone or the skeleton and we can
collect these cells from the bone marrow
and in fact we can grow them up this is
one of the unusual properties of these
cells you can take a small amount of
bone marrow from a normal person put it
into the laboratory and grow it up as
shown here in this cartoon so you can
see here in this test tube the red bone
marrow is put into a centrifuge the
cells we want are in green and over a
period of many weeks huge numbers of
these cells can be grown up and frozen
and this is what they look like under
the microscope when you put them into
culture they
stick to the bottom of the tissue of the
flask and they look like these little
spindly things and they multiply so that
you can see that now this whole plate is
filled and they're stuck to each other
we can collect these cells and then use
them for treatment what do they do they
nurture the bone marrow and this is
shown here in this experiment the term
is cobblestone II this is a picture from
one of the cobblestone streets in
Germany when I was there recently
basically this is what the cells look
like growing if you add the bone marrow
stem cells on top of these meds and
caramel stem cells they grow and make
many many colonies of bone marrow this
is called cobblestone and they look
similar to what's in the street and they
also have immunosuppressive properties
this is the first time this has been
done in humans as a paper that I wrote
almost it's more than 15 years ago the
first time that had ever been tried in
people we collected bone marrow cells we
grew the amazing camel cells and gave
them the cells to the people again with
informed consent to see how they would
see if this was possible yes it was
possible in this first in human study
and subsequently we have gone on and use
these cells as part of our therapeutic
armamentarium these cells will help bone
marrow grow faster and suppress
graft-versus-host disease this is
another example of the first in human
study this is when we took these cells
from the brother who gave the bone
marrow for the transplant in these
patients and these studies have all been
published in a series of articles this
is the the last one I'm going to show
you this is a shown here basically
indicating that the dreaded
graft-versus-host disease that is the
cells from the donor attacking the liver
attacking the kidney attacking the skin
etc this did not happen that's what this
means no graft-versus-host disease grade
0 no grafters
disease and this is another one of those
survival plots showing that in this
large number of patients predominantly
with leukemia that we were able to cure
these people so this has been a
fantastic experience this technology has
now been readily exported to places all
over the world we've had people come to
case western reserve university to learn
how to do this and go back to their
respective countries and that's shown
here on this slide you can see that
right now worldwide is more than a
hundred countries that have started
doing mesenchymal stem cell expansion
and transplantation it's been a very
lucrative thing from the technology
technologic startup companies
perspective more than 5,000 patients
have been treated and this is another
area in which I was very fortunate to
work so I wanted to take another minute
or so to thank all the people who have
been involved in these efforts certainly
the patients and families we could never
have made so much progress in the
diagnosis and treatment of some of these
blood cancers if it were not for the
very brave patients and their families
who were willing to go through a lot of
these very difficult times and now
everybody's seeing the benefits of this
kind of thing and a lot of the data also
his who have been have been that I've
shown have been generated at other
centers and building and so this is a
famous quote from Sir Isaac Newton who
said if I have seen farther than others
it is because I was standing on the
shoulders of giants so I think that's
something that's very important but
again I wanted to conclude by coming
back to my point about Carnegie Mellon
the we can do showing the logo here I
want to thank from the bottom of my
heart all the people you at Carnegie
Mellon I think it's helped instill the
spirit of discovery in me not only the
professors and the academic staff but
also my fellow students and certainly
from the
entropic support of the alumni and
friends you have established the
Carnegie Mellon culture this is a
wonderful campus where ideas and become
reality and nobody wants to go home at
the end of the day without having some
success and building so I want to thank
you for your attention and again thank
you for your helping me get to where I
am anybody have any questions on what I
yes
so the mesenchymal cells can be I the
purposes of this audience wanted to
spare you some of those details the
mesenchymal stem cells can be collected
from a variety of tissues we at Case
Western Reserve University have tended
to collect them from a small amount of
bone marrow where again if everybody in
the audience takes their thumb and puts
it on the back of your hip you can fill
that bone sticking out there that's
where we go that's called the posterior
superior crest if you put a person on
the side as I showed you and clean off
that area and put in novocaine you can
put in a small needle with a syringe and
collect a small amount of bone marrow
and then put that bone marrow after the
cells have been purified into culture
and add various things and these small
numbers of cells will grow you can also
do this with fat you can literally take
that off somebody you can do this from
from placenta fluid if there's a lot of
different issues and a lot of commercial
ventures have actually sprung up trying
to grow up these cells for marketing and
there's companies that have catchy names
that are actually doing this I you know
I think it's it's an exciting area I
don't know what the best recipe is we
like to use bone marrow and that's in
fact what we tend to do yes probability
of that means
so I'll repeat your question your
question is if the first bone marrow
transplant doesn't work can you do
another bone marrow transplant so the
long answer is number one why didn't the
first bone in our transplant work did
the cancer grow too fast and you
couldn't catch up did the bone marrow
that you put in didn't grow or did the
person have something bad happen like
graft-versus-host disease so depending
on what the answer was you may or may
not be able to do a second transplant
now if it's your own bone marrow that
you're donating where you got a cancer
but it's under control you can collect
the cells you're relying with your own
cells on chemotherapy in massive dose to
get rid of the cancer it doesn't always
work so some people who have had bone
marrow transplant using their own cells
are now a candidate to get a bone marrow
transplant from with someone else's
cells whether it's a brother or sister
or someone in the community and large
and that in fact is done somewhat
frequently so that's a fairly common
that's called a tandem transplant when a
person has had a bone marrow transplant
that has not worked after getting an
allogeneic transplant that is from
brother or sister the likelihood of then
being able to get another transplant is
less common it can be done sometimes
another donor can be used but i would
say on average i would say maybe of all
the cases it's a five percent so yeah it
can be done but you have to understand
why the first transplant was not a
success other questions
alright well thank you enjoy the weekend
and thank you for this honor it once
again